[Música]
son las 8:30 de la noche en Bogotá quito
y lima y continuamos en directo América
edición nocturna Les agradecemos su
sintonía y vamos con los titulares de
esta jornada
el gobernador del estado estadounidense
de Florida ron de santis anunciará este
miércoles su aspiración a la candidatura
republicana así lo indicó la cadena Fox
que adelantó que la presentación será
hecha a través de Twitter en
conversación con elon musk Tenemos
reporte
ya llegó a Bolivia monseñor que envió El
Vaticano para investigar los posibles
casos de pederastia el presidente de ese
país Luis Arce le pidió al Papa
Francisco que comparta todos los
archivos sobre abusos sexuales cometidos
presuntamente por religiosos
y sigue el cruce de señalamientos en
belgorot Rusia dice haber frenado la
supuesta incursión proveniente de
Ucrania en esta región fronteriza y
asegura haber asesinado a más de 70
atacantes a los que hemos señalado ser
militares ucranianos Jeff lo niega y por
el contrario Dice que son Patriotas
rusos descontentos con el crimen
[Aplausos]
[Música]
comenzamos en la ciudad de Miami donde
crece la expectativa luego de que la
cadena Fox news informara que el
Gobernador de Florida ronda santis
anunciara su aspiración a la candidatura
republicana en la tarde de este
miércoles esto a través de una
conversación con el dueño de Twitter el
multimillonario elon musk para analizar
esta noticia conectamos con César
Grajales analista político y experto en
campañas políticas Bienvenido a France
24 Cómo cambia esta candidatura el
panorama del partido republicano de Cara
a las presidenciales
buenas noches bueno esta era una anuncio
esperado desde hace semanas incluso
algunos meses y finalmente ese momento
ha llegado lo que es nuevo en toda esta
especulación del anuncio es que nadie se
esperaba por parte del gobernador que
este anuncio se haga en Twitter spaces
especialmente
Aparentemente va a ser una entrevista
conversación
entre el gobernador
y yo creo que eso le genera obviamente
atención no solamente de los
republicanos votantes que van a verlo a
él como candidato ahora a la presidencia
sobre todo a la nominación del partido
republicano pero también atrae la
atención francamente de la inmensa
mayoría del público que quiere ver esta
conversación entre el gobernador y el
dueño de Twitter que también tiene sus
seguidores y en muchos de sus tweets
genera
conversación y genera controversia en
muchas ocasiones Así que vamos a ver
cómo sale ese anuncio para el gobernador
el día de mañana Bueno las leyes y
posiciones firmes de santis
considerablemente radicales y han
permitido ganar apoyos de algunos
sectores
aquí es que los candidatos que están
corriendo dentro del partido en este
momento republicano no están haciendo
campaña pensando en la elección general
de noviembre del próximo año 2024 están
haciendo campaña pensando en ganar la
nominación del partido republicano en
ese aspecto Pues los políticos van
tomando diferentes Caminos Diferentes
acercamientos en términos de política
pública y propuestas
se ha hablado incluso bueno el tema de
el gobernador con la disputa con Disney
el tema migratorio
muchos otros temas que en algunos
sectores quizá ha incomodado pero en el
estado de la Florida la popularidad del
gobernador sigue Más allá del 50% el año
el año pasado ganó con 20 puntos de
ventaja la reelección y en el condado de
Miami y un condado demócrata por más de
20 años
ganó por muchos puntos que quiere decir
que independientes y demócratas algunos
demócratas y republicanos votaron por él
en esa elección y es una elección
reciente Así que yo creo que en ese
aspecto No creo que las políticas
públicas que han pasado en los últimos
semanas le vayan a afectar yo creo que
más bien tiene que hacer su estrategia
claramente para ganar votos electorales
en otros estados fuera de la Florida
Pues señor Grajales a usted muchas
gracias por su análisis y por
compartirlo con nosotros en France 24
gracias buenas noches También en Estados
Unidos fue publicado un informe de la
fiscalía del Estado de Illinois que
detalla que unos 2.000 menores de edad
fueron abusados sexualmente por 451
integrantes de la Iglesia Católica entre
1950 y 2010 el texto de 696 páginas de
talla que los líderes católicos
toleraron y ocultaron casos las cifras
mucho mayor a la de 103 personas que la
Iglesia Católica había señalado cuando
inició la investigación en 2018
es importante no ignorar la historia de
cómo se manejaron estos asuntos antes de
la investigación
y lo que eso requiere en términos de
transparencia y credibilidad en términos
de cualquier investigación futura
entonces para mí eso requeriría personas
creíbles fuera que la iglesia se
involucre en esas investigaciones
y llegó a Bolivia
el enviado del Papa Francisco para
investigar los casos de pederastia
presuntamente cometidos por curas
católicos si bien la conferencia
episcopal boliviana aclaró que su visita
estaba pactada desde antes el religioso
llega cuando el país se enfrenta un
escándalo por la publicación de un
diario en el que un sacerdote reconoce
haber abusado de 85 menores de edad el
presidente Luis Arce le pidió al
Vaticano que investigara Ramiro cueva
Barberena no se amplía
la conmoción continuó en Bolivia luego
de que se develará El Diario del difunto
sacerdote jesuita Alfonso pedrajas donde
confesaba haber abusado de por lo menos
84 menores durante su estadía en el país
dirigiendo escuelas para comunidades
marginadas al respecto la presidencia
boliviana informó que Se reserva el
derecho de admisión de nuevos religiosos
extranjeros y que envió una carta al
Vaticano con una petición al Papa
Francisco
que la justicia boliviana pueda acceder
a todos los archivos expedientes e
información referente a estas denuncias
y hechos de abuso sexuales cometidos por
sacerdotes y religiosos católicos en
territorio boliviano tras la difusión
del contenido del Diario de pedrajas la
justicia boliviana recibió al menos ocho
denuncias por pederastia y algunas
víctimas se animan a querer contar su
caso
sólo pido justicia
porque nunca más se repitan agresiones y
hechos abominables contra seres
indefensos y estoy dispuesto y me lo
juego todo
algunos preguntan Y por qué ahora y por
qué yo respondo le digo sabes qué
preguntas las
salen sobrando porque no sabes el
calvario que hemos vivido durante la
última semana Se realizaron
allanamientos en algunas escuelas
incluyendo el tradicional san Calixto y
la curia provincial en La Paz El
objetivo del gobierno boliviano está
definido esclarecer los hechos y
encontrar justicia para las víctimas en
otras noticias la cancillería de
Colombia le pidió al gobierno de chile
que castiga los responsables de la
muerte del colombiano Milton Rodríguez
una obra en situación de discapacidad el
pasado viernes en la ciudad chilena de
iqueque cuatro miembros de la armada del
país austral lo habrían golpeado varias
veces incluso con las muletas que usaba
la cancillería colombiana afirmó que
Milton murió por la gravedad de sus
heridas y por eso le pidió a Chile que
se tomen acciones legales Más allá de la
suspensión de los funcionarios
y la justicia colombiana determinó
mantener abierto un caso contra el
expresidente Álvaro Uribe por presunto
soborno a testigos y fraude procesal
según la jueza encargada Sí hay pruebas
de que el ex mandatario pudo participar
en la manipulación de Testigos a través
de uno de sus ex abogados por lo que
podría ir a juicio en agosto pasado la
fiscalía había pedido el cierre del caso
pero la funcionaria determinó que no se
investigó lo suficiente abrívelo acusan
de supuestamente intentar comprar
testigos que lo señalaban de ser
promotor del paramilitarismo
Este martes se reanudó la búsqueda de
madeleine la menor británica que
desapareció en 2007 cuando tenía 3 años
mientras pasaba sus vacaciones de verano
en una región del sur de Portugal la
búsqueda se retomó a petición de
Alemania que acusó formalmente a un
sospechoso por el hecho en 2022 y
asegura que este mató a la menor hace 16
años Marta Moya tiene más detalles en el
informe
16 años y una nueva búsqueda ilusionante
la petición de las autoridades alemanas
Este martes la policía portuguesa retomó
en la presa de silves al sur del país
las pesquisas de Madeline la menor
británica desaparecida en 2007 mientras
pasaba sus vacaciones de verano en una
localidad de la costa lusa Aunque el
embalse ya se rastreó en 2008 sin éxito
ahora un ex detective que jugó un papel
central en las investigaciones comentó
que hay motivos para tener doble
Esperanza
una policía alemana sigue al ritmo no se
quita la presión sigue invirtiendo
recursos y número dos en algún momento
tiene que haber un gran Avance en este
caso en algún momento la suerte tiene
que cambiar
Alemania identificó formalmente a su
conciudano Christian broker como
sospechoso oficial de la desaparición de
la menor
la fiscalía está investigando a un
ciudadano Alemán de 43 años sospechoso
asesinato asumimos que la está muerta
el presunto autor ha negado cualquier
vinculación con el caso y aunque no está
condenado por ello se encuentra entre
rejas por abuso a otros menores tráfico
de drogas y la violación a una mujer de
72 años en la misma zona donde se perdió
el rastro de macán pese a lo mediático
del caso y las investigaciones conjuntas
entre Lisboa Londres y Berlín desde 2007
no ha habido avances significativos
sobre el paradero de la niña que
desapareció en una casa estival mientras
sus padres cenaban con unos amigos en un
bar cercano a la residencia vamos con
noticias de la guerra en Ucrania el
kremlin afirma que ya terminó la
incursión militar en la región rusa
agregó que mataron al menos 70 atacantes
oscuros plegó desde el lunes una
operación antiterrorista dirigida por el
ejército creado a poderes excepcionales
por su parte Ucrania niega a estar
involucrada y dice que fue un ataque
realizado por rusos
este combatiente cubre la letra Z uno de
los símbolos del ejército de Vladimir
Putin en su lugar una viñeta que
representa el cuerpo de voluntarios
rusos un grupo ferozmente opuesto al
kremlin y que habría participado en la
incursión de virgoroth la más grave en
el territorio ruso desde el inicio de la
guerra en dos días varias localidades de
velgorod han sido atacadas por boca del
portavoz del Ministerio de defensa ruso
Moscú afirma que la ofensiva ha
terminado y acusa directamente a kiev
durante la operación antiterrorista
gracias a los ataques aéreos y de
artillería y a la acción de las unidades
de defensa fronteriza del distrito
militar occidental las formaciones
nacionalistas ucranianas fueron
bloqueadas y aplastadas
añade que en este contraataque murieron
70 ucranianos esta información es
imposible de verificar el gobierno de
kiev niega cualquier implicación en esta
incursión sin embargo la operación Fue
reivindicada en un canal de Telegram que
se presenta como perteneciente a un
grupo de rusos que luchan en el bando
ucraniano
es hora de poner fin a la Dictadura del
kremlin Muchas gracias a todos los que
nos apoyan y nos envían donativos su
apoyo es lo que nos recuerda cada día
Nuestro objetivo final en la plaza Roja
de Moscú sean valientes y no tengan
miedo porque volvemos a casa Rusia será
libre
el lunes Rusia declaró una operación
antiterrorista en la región
fronteriza con Ucrania una medida que
dio a las autoridades más poderes para
llevar a cabo operaciones armadas o
evacuar a la población el periodista de
The Wall Street journal
deberá permanecer arrestado en Rusia
hasta el 30 de agosto y no hasta el 29
de mayo como estaba previsto justo
después de conocer la noticia el
gobierno de Estados Unidos instó a
liberarlo inmediatamente el reportero
está detenido desde marzo y es acusado
por cargos de espionaje que podrían
conllevar a una pena de hasta 20 años de
prisión
entendemos que se llevó a cabo la
audiencia y que Rusia extendió la
detención preventiva de Evans por tres
meses más una vez más hacemos un llamado
a Rusia para que cumpla con su
obligación de proporcionarle acceso
consular como comentaba ayer rechazaron
nuestra segunda solicitud de acceso
consular de afirmaciones contra Evans
son infundadas y seguimos pidiendo su
Liberación inmediata
así llegamos al final de esta emisión de
directo a América aquí en France 24
ustedes Les agradecemos su sintonía y
los invitamos a continuar con nosotros
que ya llega herminia Fernández Con toda
la información de nuestra red de
corresponsales en el mundo feliz noche
para todos
[Música]